I think the game of the press conference
all of us judging by the reaction was
for honor oh yeah so look at single
player from the sounds of it sounds like
there's three single player campaign
that was the vibe I got yeah yeah yeah
it was wasn't super clear but they were
talking they described what each
campaign would essentially entail yeah
unless oh yeah they it will remains to
be seen I guess but it seems very likely
that each of the factions will get their
own campaign but what's interesting is
that they said that you know as the
Knights he joined the Blackstone legions
as the samurai trying to prevent a civil
war and then when it came to the Vikings
they showed this which is the Vikings
directly attacking some things I'll be
interested to see if you did play all
three campaigns how much it overlap and
interaction there it has a bit
intertwined in some way that'd be really
cool I'm also hoping that it's kind of
story driven or there's a little more
substance to and it's not just you know
preparing you for the multiplayer yeah a
lot of developers seem to be doing that
kind of thing now siege is another
ubisoft game you know they had these
sort of single-player missions but
really they were just kind of teaching
the mechanic so you could jump into
multiplayer and they were fun but it
wasn't really a true campaign so kind of
hoping for honor like really goes for it
and does a robust complete story driven
campaign it looks stunning as well as a
combat seems to flow really well and
like we was discussing earlier it looks
like there is a lot of nuance and
strategy to the to the moment-to-moment
gameplay and combat and there was a lot
of contextual combat as well yeah yeah
throwing off at the top people being
thrown to the spice yeah yeah be quite
interested to see how the combat differs
between each faction like the vibe we
got from the Vikings is that their big
heavy hitters there was a lot of weight
behind all that moves I'd assume that
the samurai a bit more fluid bit more
hard shell maybe the Knights or
somewhere in between but not only could
there be three different stories baby
like three different ways to play as
well yeah which be very exciting and
also I mean a lot of the comparisons
online were saying it looks a lot like
rise son of Rome I'm definitely getting
that vibe but it I don't know there's
something more about this game it looks
more interesting to me than I mean when
you look at the story mode it kind of
feels in terms of the scope and the set
piece is almost god of war ish yes and
then when you're in a big battle just
like it's almost dynasty worried assoc
like you just kind of like rushing
through this area to thinning out the
hordes of you know enemies too
to this one point where a special type
is there so you can wipe em out and move
on it looks like it's drawing from a lot
of these games and it's just the level
of Polish that we already seeing is
really really like exciting and it looks
like they've figured out how they want
combat to work and they've seemed to
have made it look fluid and and like
yeah interesting so yeah I'm really
exciting it was probably the game of
their showing yeah for sure